foreign
[Music]
Coleman flowers you are an activist an
author an entrepreneur
and the Arthur genius award recipient
and now a Forbes 50 over 50. thank you
so much for being here thank you for
having me you do such important work in
the area of environmental justice but I
want to start with a few definitions for
folks who might be watching and who
might not be familiar with your work
how would you define or describe
environmental justice well I think the
best way to describe environmental
justice is to give an example of
communities that are chosen for sighting
of dirty plants because they are too
poor to fight
and there are examples in this country
like in cancer alley the examples to our
Appalachia you know the examples
everywhere you look where
companies tend to cite places that
pollute in areas where the the incomes
are low or they're people of color
and those are environmental justice
communities
you have been working to fight something
that you call America's dirty secret
what is America's dirty secret America's
dirty secret is is that the richest
country in the world
has people living with no sanitation
with sewage running either on top of the
ground outside of their homes or coming
back into their homes
and I think that most Americans don't
even know that this exists and that's
why we call it America's dirty Secret
you have described yourself as an
accidental activist you have activism in
your DNA but you kind of came to this
issue
not intentionally but it has become your
life's work how did you get into this uh
well before I was a teacher and when I
moved back to Alabama people were being
arrested in Lowndes County Alabama
because they could not afford on-site
septic and then we found out it was more
than that and from that led to us doing
a house to house survey to find out how
how many people were impacted and then
we partnered with Bayless National
School of tropical medicine and did a
parasite study where we found that
hookworm which is something that is is
more known to exist in developing
countries existed here in the U.S and
that's when we started to get attention
so it was a long long process it didn't
happen overnight and a lot of people
didn't want to talk about sanitation
they didn't want to talk about sewage
and we just had to be persistent and
work with Scientists to be able to show
that this was a real problem that we
need to address
just to rewind you mentioned people
getting arrested because they weren't
handling the sewage
that sounds insane to put it frankly how
why was that happening what was the
structure of the community such that
this burden was on individual people
well in a lot of rural communities the
sanitation responsibilities on the
individual homeowners
and this was true in Alabama so in
Lowndes County Alabama which is located
between Selma and Montgomery people were
left to their own devices to figure it
out so if they couldn't figure it out
that there was a state policy that they
would be cited if they didn't if
somebody reported them or if they found
out they did not have adequate
sanitation the State Health Department
would cite them and then if the people
were not in a position financially where
they could put in place a septic system
that the state approved then they would
the next step would be that they would
be cited for violating uh an order of
the court and that's how people ended up
being arrested
were you looking into economic
development for the region at the time
was that the very first question you
were trying to answer how do we get more
businesses here
but when I that was my first job in
Lowndes County the county hired me as
their Economic Development coordinator
and I quickly found out that without
infrastructure without working
infrastructure you're not going to have
any Economic Development so a lot of
these poor communities are relegated to
remaining poor without infrastructure
that's why it's so important for me to
see that there's an emphasis on
infrastructure and hopefully putting
infrastructure in places that never had
it before you know and my role is the
White House environmental justice
advisory Council uh co-chair co-vice
chair one of the things that we found
one of the definitions that I think that
that really help people to see this is
that these are Under resourced and
overburdened communities and the same in
those same communities EJ communities
have not had the type of investment
necessary in infrastructure and this was
one example and what was so glaring
about this example is that every year
people go to Selma from Montgomery to
commemorate the Voting Rights movement
and the Voting Rights march and we're
passing through this area and didn't
realize that this was a glaring example
of the inequality around sanitation that
we have in this country so they're
passing through and it's just happening
just outside of the main road so it's
behind view for people people don't you
can't see it you have to actually go to
someone's home this is not the kind of
discussion that the average person would
have and say you know my sewage isn't
working it's out in my backyard most
people are embarrassed about it but one
of the things I think that we've done is
have taken the shame away from
sanitation and talking about it because
this is the only way we're going to find
real solutions to this problem so you
start looking into Economic Development
and infrastructure and you realize this
is a problem and you re wrote in your
book that no one really counted the
number of homes affected until you did
can you talk about going door to door
and coming up with the number
quantifying the scale of this issue
well we we felt that in order for people
to understand
the whole narrative around this we need
to go to the community and find out so
what we did was we found the community
leaders we didn't want elected officials
involved in this we asked people to
recommend folk that were very
influential in the communities but they
were not elected officials they didn't
hold any position they were just
Community people that folk trusted and
we found those people and they're the
ones that went from house to house
because keep in mind there was a law
that could have uh if they had revealed
that they didn't have sanitation people
could have ended up in jail you know
they could have ended up being forced
off their property so whoever they gave
this information to had to be a trusted
member of the community and that's why
we chose trusted members uh the county
itself has five County Commission
districts we divided it up into five
five different areas with people that
lived in those districts that were the
ones that went from house to house to do
this survey
you do the survey you quantify the scale
of the problem
fast forward a few years and actually
quite recently you and the nrdc filed
suit against the county or the state of
Alabama well the nrdc and we have
actually filed a civil rights complaint
with the
um we filed a civil rights complaint
with with EPA we're still waiting to see
what's happening with that but the other
complaint that we filed with Earth
Justice that was in 2017. we filed that
complaint because when we did our
parasite study
the state of Alabama put on his website
that the parasite study was not credible
because we didn't use FDA approved
technology to to do to run the tests on
the samples the FDA approved technology
they were talking about was PCR
technology which if you fast forward PCR
technology was used to determine whether
or not people had coveted but that was
the same type of Technology we had used
and we went to earthjustice who worked
with us and we filed this complaint
that became the first ever complaint
accepted by doj environmental justice
complaint using civil rights law to to
do an investigation and they actually
investigated the State Department of
Public Health and recently announced
that they have the first ever settlement
using using civil rights law to deal
with environmental justice I I have part
of that statement that was just in May
that was very recently they said this
agreement marks the first time that the
justice department has secured a
resolution agreement in an environmental
justice investigation under title VI of
the Civil Rights Act of 1964 and while
this may be the first it certainly won't
be our last so let's break that down a
little bit what does this settlement
mean for Lowndes County first of all it
validates what local people have been
saying all the time about the issues in
Lowndes County and how the state has
been a culprit in in terms of
I think enabling it to continue they
thought they were doing something to
stop it but they were not stopping it
but now with this with this particular
agreement I think there's an opportunity
for the state to start for the first
time hopefully working with local people
to find real solutions to this because
it has to be documented one of some of
the the actions that they were taking
against local people were not conducive
to a solution and now with the with the
federal government being involved also
making sure that the funding is
available so that there could be help
because there was a time they were
saying when I first got involved they
said there was no money available it was
always up to the individual homeowners
who couldn't afford it because they were
poor and then they say this will not be
the last and so we've been talking about
Lowndes County but can you kind of widen
your lens nationally how big of an issue
is this how widespread is it happening
in all of our communities and we just
don't know it's happening in all of our
communities and we just don't know in
rural communities throughout the United
States people are dealing with the same
issue and then with climate change you
know with sea level rise there are
communities that have relied on septic
tanks on-site septic they're not working
and when they fail the sewage either
goes out into their backyards and to the
street or into their homes and we've
been in communities around the country
we've been asked to come to Miami they
have a major problem with failing septic
systems next month we'll be in Hawaii
they're moving from cesspools to septic
and septics we know are failing likewise
we were recently in California they they
know that in California there are lots
of people on septic but they don't know
how many are on septic so they're hoping
to to launch a program over the next
four years where they will move from
septic to sewer so we're hoping that as
we go to these different communities
that we help policy makers understand
this is a major problem and it's in your
backyard too
as we talk about sanitation in rural
communities and the issues that you've
been uncovering it strikes me that
is sanitation a human right how is this
happening
sanitation is a human right and actually
when I got involved with this before we
got all this attention we went to the
U.N
and there are sustainable development
goals that the UN has and one of them is
the human rights award and sanitation
and it's it's all connected and I do
believe that it is a human right because
humans cannot live without water
and we can't be healthy without
Sanitation
how are so many homes without this
fundamental human right
I believe that so many homes are without
this fundamental uh human right because
of inequality
I think there are structural
inequalities that are in place that have
been able this to happen far too long
and we can remove a lot of those
structural inequalities I think that
everyone would have the right toward and
sanitation no matter where they are as I
dug into this research I felt ashamed
that I didn't know that this was
happening to this degree why do you
think there's that information or
knowledge Gap
well first of all because most of us
when we flush our toilets we don't care
where it goes
that's number one but those people that
flush their toilets and they see where
it goes then they're you know of course
they know a little bit more about this
than usual and then when I first started
doing this work I was told that the
major media wasn't interested in this I
found that not to be the case once they
became aware but I think that a lot of
people
unfortunately have chosen to look the
other way the people that do know about
this or they blamed it on the the the
homeowners the people that were dealing
with the failures and and the narrative
has been oh they don't know how to
maintain these systems but if they're
failing everywhere then maybe we need to
look at the systems themselves and
that's what we're doing we're looking at
how we can redesign these systems so
that they can work and they can work
understanding that climate change is
real and that with all these elements
that impact how we treat sanitation that
we have to look at that when we look at
this redesign and figure out a way in
which we may be able to reuse some of
the sewage instead of it just being
waste
is that where founding your organization
comes into play when did you decide to
start your own organization dedicated to
this issue well we actually started
initially back in 2002 but the Center
for Rural Enterprise and environmental
justice became a reality in 2019. 2019
so very recent very recent how's it
going I was going very very well because
people are paying attention now and a
lot of people who never saw themselves
in the sanitation issue until now are
reaching out to us and wanted to partner
and collaborate on finding long-term
Solutions let's
Partnerships because you mentioned local
leaders and earlier we were talking
about infrastructure Forbes has a
business community that we talk to all
the time where what is the role of the
business community of the private sector
in this issue if any I think there is a
role for the private sector I think the
role of the private sector is to partner
with us because one of the things that
we bring to the table is our experience
with Community engagement and I think
that that's why people didn't know that
this problem exists is existed the
community was not a part of of even
defining what the problem was so that we
can talk about what the solution is and
I think that if we could work together
and what we're looking for are partners
and collaborators on redesigning the way
we look at on-site sanitation redesign
the way we look at sanitation in general
because it's not just feeling in places
like Lowndes County we were in a place
not very far from New York City in Mount
Vernon New York there's their sanitation
was failing too and sewage was coming
back into their homes we've been called
to Detroit to work there but we have to
work with corporately leaders because
they have a lot of the technicians a lot
of the engineers that are there who can
work with us and go into the community
and together come up with design
solutions that could help us deal with
these problems and we're also looking at
federal agencies that people haven't
partnered with before like NASA I mean
on the space
in on the space shuttle
um in the International Space Station
they have to you know they have to deal
with sanitation because humans are there
but one of national NASA's missions is
when they go places to look for water
water is a part of this equation so
we're hoping that we could use some of
NASA's uh extraterrestrial knowledge to
do some Earthly good as you talk about
doing Earthly good in some of the
Partnerships that you could make what
are the Partnerships that you already
have made that have been successful and
perhaps offer lessons to others who are
working in this space or other spaces
and wanting to create change well a lot
of our our partners
our first partners and and our the
longest Partners we have are the social
justice organizations like the Equal
justice initiative or organizations like
the nrdc which you mentioned earlier of
Justice the climate reality project
they've all been very very helpful but
we're also looking to partner with
organizations one one Court one new
organization that we're partnering with
which is
um there they are using 3D technology in
order to they've built the lunar habitat
it's a group called icon they're out of
Texas and that's what one group that
we're partnering with we're also looking
at partnering with people that are
working with renewable energy because
renewable energy is part of the solution
as well in these communities especially
with redesigning sanitation so we're
always open and looking to partnering
with folk that we haven't been able to
get their attention yet and hopefully
from this we'll get their attention and
we can work on this because this is not
just an American problem this is a
global problem and if we could find a
solution and I think corporations have
the the capacity to to not only help us
find a solution but to scale it up and
make it available in all those other
areas around the world that are so in
need of this technology
entrepreneurs can help too you are an
entrepreneur you've started an
organization but for folks who are
watching so that climate change
exacerbates this issue if someone out
there is working in the area of climate
Tech what's your call to action for them
what could they build or do that would
help resolve this issue
well first of all I think the first step
is going into the communities where the
failures are taking place in talking to
people about what the failures look like
so that we can design to eliminate them
I think that's the first step and then
the second step is I don't think that
there's going to be this is not like
building a car or you're going to find a
put it on the assembly line and mass
produce it it's going to be different
for different areas because we have
different geological factors impacting
how it works so if you're in an area
with a higher water table that's going
to be different than being in a desert
area or making sure that it's something
that can be used in the colonies you
know we got all these these uh
communities that are located along the
Texas and Texas border with Mexico and
going all the way really to California
and a lot of people have these same
issues but making sure that it's
something that can be I believe that you
can go to a Lowe's or Home Depot and buy
so that everybody can have access to it
and I think if we have that as a
standard I believe that we will be able
to get this technology the new
technology that comes about to everyone
that needs it
that's the solution side of this but I
still go back to some of the scenes that
you describe in your book of the sewage
leaking into people's backyards children
not being able to play
and it feels to me as if someone needs
to be held accountable are there people
who have lost their jobs over this not
yet
you know I think that part of this
Paradigm that makes it so strange to me
is that the the onus is on the home
homeowners
we believe that one way we can get this
technology change right away
is that when you buy the the technology
it should come with a warranty
you know they don't come it doesn't come
with a warranty the the liability is
transferred to the homeowner immediately
immediately so we feel that if they came
with you know maybe a 10-year warranty
they came with a 10-year warranty uh I
mean personally I believe that it should
be the life of a mortgage if it's
associated with the life of a mortgage
certainly they would work better and
they would work longer so those are some
of the things that that I think needs to
happen to to address it right away so
the liability will not just be on the
homeowner I think that we should also
Design Systems that can be maintained
within the home that won't need some
type of
organization to oversee it or another
utility or another layer of government
to oversee it and those are the kinds of
things that I think that could help us
along the way to get to where we need to
be it sounds like there's a lot of work
ahead there's a lot of work ahead are
you optimistic about the ability to
create real change here I'm very
optimistic why I'm very optimistic
because
if a country girl from Lowndes County
Alabama
can make Forbes 50 over 50.
the sky's the limit among the
discoveries you have forged is a really
troubling one about tropical diseases
and hookworm can you talk about exactly
what you uncovered here
well we were
you know hearing local people talk about
the possibility of illnesses that were
related to sewage being on the ground I
had my own experience where I was called
to a site and I had on a dress was
bitten by mosquitoes that were nesting
on raw sewage and from that my body
broke out in the rash and I was trying
to determine what was wrong and I asked
my doctor who ran a series of blood
tests on me that came back negative and
I said is it possible that American
doctors are not even trained to look for
these kinds of illnesses associated with
raw sewage because this isn't supposed
to be a problem in the United States
and she's saying yeah it's possible so I
saw an opiate that was in the New York
Times that was written by
Dr Peter hotez who was at Bayless
National School of tropical medicine and
I Googled him and found his email
address and I wrote him and I asked him
that question I said is it possible that
uh people could have diseases from raw
sewage being on the ground that American
doctors are not trained to look for he
wrote me back and said yes he said I
always talk about this but every time I
talk about the tropical parasites
potentially being in the U.S they want
to blame it on immigration
I said I can take you to a place where
people probably hadn't been to Atlanta
let alone out of the country and that's
how we did the parasite study and then
the NIH picked it up well what happened
was uh once we
we collected the same local people that
went from house to house and did the
survey
they also collected
um we they were involved in going
because they had the trust of the
community people had to give us their
fecal samples
and their blood samples so the community
these same Community activists help us
collect those samples we got them to the
doctors at Baylor who were there they
gave us you know with the uh the
protocols were and they were tested and
then it there was a three-year
um period that we had to go through peer
review and once the once the peer review
was completed because without that it
wouldn't have been valid
um that came out in 2017 and from that
uh the CDC NIH and others have gotten
involved since that time because people
realize that this is a problem and not
just in Lowndes County but we were the
first to acknowledge that it is a
problem and provide um
and provide evidence that there's a
problem here in the United States the
White House has taken notice too correct
yes the White House is taking notice can
you tell me I'm going to read my paper
so I get the name right what is the
closing America's Wastewater Gap
initiative
well it was announced in August of last
year it was the first ever National
recognition that there is a Wastewater
access Gap here in the U.S and there are
11 counties from throughout the U.S that
are part of it but it started out of our
work in Lowndes County Alabama I was
told that the president saw an article
in the New York Times where I was quoted
saying that the only way we were going
to get to sanitation Equity is the way
we got voting rights it's through
Federal intervention and we heard from
the White House and and eventually the
EPA administrator the USDA secretary and
the infrastructures are came to Lowndes
County to announce this this first ever
initiative
what's it going to do what's the
the long-term goal is to make sure that
every American has access to work and
sanitation and earlier we talked about
infrastructure economic development is
that possible yet in Lowndes County for
businesses to come in or are we still a
ways off from that
from my Economic Development days what I
do know is that if there is a business
that wants to locate in Lowndes County
especially in communities like White
Hall Alabama we could get the
infrastructure dollars and put in the
right type of infrastructure that can
support their being there but it can
also provide not only jobs for the
community but it can provide access to
the type of infrastructure that the
community needs in order to grow and
thrive so that is uh that's what we hope
will ultimately come of this
what's next for you what is on your
to-do list if you look at the next one
two five ten years what do you want to
accomplish
well I like to use my story to inspire
young people to not give up
to let them know that it's never too
late you can always start over
and I call it The Nine Lives of cat
because I've had at least nine lives so
I just believe that that I would like to
just for my legacy to be an inspiration
for the generations to come
I have to work for as long as I to work
for as long as you can well to that
point we are here for the 50 over 50 and
we have a few kind of standard questions
we always ask
when you were younger did you ever
imagine your career over the age of 50
and if so what did you imagine and how
does the reality compare
when I was younger people were retiring
at 50. so so I didn't I
I didn't imagine that my career would be
what it is now
but as I got closer to 50
my goals and objectives change
and I feel that once we get to a certain
point in life there's wisdom
my parents used to talk to me about
wisdom and I didn't understand what they
meant at the time but there's something
that you will only know if you just
lived
you know my mama used to say all the
time just keep on living so the fact
that I've lived this long and I've seen
a variety of things has helped me to be
able to to focus a little bit more on
the things that I'm trying to accomplish
but to me when I looked back at you know
when I was younger and looking now I
never thought or imagined that I would
be where I am right now
speaking of wisdom we always like to ask
people is being over 50 an advantage or
disadvantage in your line of work and a
lot of people talk about wisdom and
experience when they answer that
question but what would you say activism
is hard work long hours is your age an
advantage or disadvantage in what you're
doing I think my age is an advantage
because I've learned how to get along
with people
you know you have to be able to talk to
each other
and one of the things that I don't like
about what I'm seeing in this country is
that people are not listening to each
other
they're talking at each other
and one of the things I've learned how
to do is to holler to sit down and have
a conversation no matter if I'm in a red
or a blue state
if I'm even talking to somebody that I
don't just that I don't agree with all
the time but to be able to have that
conversation and have the patience to
sit down
knowing that they might say some things
that are inflammatory but not responding
to it but hoping that we come away from
there with one thing one shared value
that we have in common and I've learned
that with age because when I was younger
I didn't have the patience to sit around
long enough to listen so is that the key
to having bipartisan conversations
patients
and growing up in a rare state
you know growing up in a red State there
are certain skills I had to learn if I
was going to stay there and I had to
learn those and part of that is finding
those things that we have in common and
and and that has um
that has been very helpful I've been a
very helpful skill to me uh in terms of
the work that I'm doing and and and
Wastewater doesn't care if if sewage is
coming back into your home it doesn't
care what party you're in doesn't care
how much money you have people are
impacted the same way do some have more
money to fix it than others but in terms
of the impact I think that it is um it's
it's pretty much the same across the
board so it provides a type of uh
platform for me to talk to people across
various spectrums you had a really
interesting example in your book I think
it was Jeff sessions which in other
politicians who have I think at this
moment in time a certain aura or
reputation and what's been the secret to
sitting down and creating real
conversation with them is it that it
goes back to patients I think the secret
sauce is meeting people where they are
and when Jeff sessions and I met I was
at a town hall meeting in Lowndes County
and I asked a question because he was
talking about all the federal funds that
were available at that time
for you know rural communities
and I asked the question how does rural
communities get access and they don't
even have grant writers and you're also
requiring that they have a 25 match
he couldn't answer the question but he
came to me afterwards and he said I've
always wanted to answer that question I
like to know do you have any ideas
because I'm from a rural community too
you know I would like to find solutions
to that and that's how we struck up a
friendship
that's incredible
what is your advice to women in their
20s and 30s who feel like they have to
rush to fit all the accomplishments in
before the age of 40 or even before the
age of 30.
you sit here almost 65 what's your
advice to them
live life
don't put a
don't put a clock
you know or a time limit on your
accomplishments because the
accomplishments that you will make in
your 20s would be different from the
accomplishments in your 30s and 40s and
you may even change in your 50s and do
something completely different
and I have my my model the person that I
look to is Jane Fonda
who has reinvented herself so many times
and it's still very relevant today and I
think if they had a role model to look
to that was over 50. that could give
them an inspiration and also give them
what they need when those times get get
hard and they feel like they're not
going to get to the other side but they
would get there they just need to have
that wisdom and that uh the spirit guide
to help them get to where they need to
be
what do you consider your greatest over
50 accomplishment
my greatest over 50 accomplishment was
the day that I went to the White House
had a chance to go to the Oval Office
and walk out with the president to heal
to the chief
and in the Rose Garden and I got to
introduce them
that was I think one of that was the
greatest accomplishment and I realized
then that apparently we had made some
Headway apparently and I understand you
almost didn't take that trip what else
was happening in your life at that time
well my granddaughter was was expected
to be born any day and as a grandma my
job was to get my grandson and let him
stay with me while his mom was in the
hospital so when they reached out to me
I said I don't think I could come
because you know I have a duty to
perform form and it just so happened
that Halo helped me along by coming
earlier early enough so that I could
actually go to the White House and
introduce the president
the work you're doing is leaving a
legacy for millions of people around the
country but also your family what is the
Legacy you want to leave to them
I want my family to know that
there is no problem that's
insurmountable
just be persistent
[Music]